okay good afternoon i'm assistant
sheriff brett zimmerman and i'm here to
brief you
on additional details as we know them
today about the officer-involved
shooting
that occurred on tuesday december 8 2020
this is ois number 18 for 2020
fatal number 10. same time last year we
were at ois number 16
and fatal number four date and time and
type of call
is december 8th 2020 at 1 20 a.m
and the call was a burglary the location
of the ois was at the 5100 block of
spanish heights drive
las vegas nevada 89148
which is in the summerlin area command
and you can see the scene to my left on
the map
involved officers are officer malik
grego hyphenated smith that first name
is spelled
m-a-l-i-k middle name g-r-e-g-o
then the hyphen and smith common
spelling he's 40 years old and has been
with lvmpd since 2008.
in this incident officer grego smith was
armed with a glock 17
nine millimeter handgun equipped with a
tactical light
the ins the investigation revealed he
fired three rounds during the incident
the second officer is officer dustin
zapanya
his name is spelled x's and x-ray a y
a-y-p-a-n-y-a
he is 25 years old and has been with the
lvmpd since 2018.
in this incident officer zapanya was
armed with a glock 45
nine millimeter handgun equipped with a
tactical light
the investigation revealed he fired
three rounds during this incident
our suspect is a nathaniel sironin
his name is up on the uh television and
that's the spelling of the name
he's 40 years old and he's a white male
adult
5 feet 11 and weighs 160 pounds
again picture to my left the suspect's
weapon he was armed with a hammer
and the photo again is up to my left
mr sironin's charges if he had survived
were burglary
kidnapping two counts robbery and
assault with a deadly weapon
the details of the ois are as follows on
tuesday december 8th 2020 at
approximately 1
20 a.m lvmpd dispatch center
received a burglary in progress call for
a residence located in the 5100 block
of spanish heights drive the person
reported
the person reporting stated that her
home alarm system
had been activated and that a male
intruder was in her home
and he was armed with a hammer the
intruder was later identified as
nathaniel
sironin patrol officers were dispatched
to the residence
and officers gregor smith and zapana
arrived at the residence
a few minutes later as the officers
approached the residence
officer griego smith observed mr sironen
standing in the kitchen
the officers rushed up to the front door
and told the homeowner to unlock the
door
as the front door was opened and the
officers were making entry
mr sironan ran towards the male
homeowner while holding a hammer over
his head ready to strike
officer grego smith and officer zapanya
both charged
both discharged their weapons striking
mr sironin
officers immediately summoned medical
personnel by mr cerrone and succumbed to
his injuries on the scene
through the course of the investigation
it was revealed that mr sironin made
entry through the house
through a side door that has access to
the garage and the house
once inside the residence the suspect
confronted the homeowners
armed with a hammer and demanded to know
where the money was
once mr cerrone noticed that the
officers were outside
he demanded the keys to the victim's car
and told the homeowner's wife
that she was coming with him at this
moment is when the homeowner ran to the
front door
and unlocked the door for the officers
and at this time i'll show you the body
worn camera footage
oh yeah the mail or
oh yeah there is a dude inside
robert 34 give us a ride real quick the
suspect is actually inside the house
open the door
[ __ ]
says it slowed down obviously
and there's a still shot it's a little
hard to see in the actual body-worn
camera because it goes quick but
that's the view of what the officer saw
arm on the homeowner
raising the hammer to strike him that's
when the officers decided to fire to
save the homeowner's life
and that'll conclude my briefing there's
any questions yes
i know that dirt hill street you know
if did he jump the wall to get into the
community do you know how he got in
there we
we don't know how he got in but what we
do know
that security had observed a male in a
construction
uh in a home under construction on that
street
minutes prior so they had gone out on
the individual
they lit the gen they lit the person up
and uh prior to that
that was the call that security had
gotten so we don't we don't know how he
got in but
you know there's obviously uh you know
any way to get in besides getting in the
front gate over there there's got to be
a nook and cranny he could have snuck in
that but
we feel he was possibly at a previous
home under construction prior
and then wound up in this other location
in the homeowner's home
to commit a burglary
i would say within
three yards and looking at the videos is
it two yards
was it two okay two yards but in looking
at that it was it was
it was pretty close and the homeowner
was not injured
homeowner was not injured
was unlocked yes the homeowner what
what happened was is there was an
emergency door apparently in that
residence
a home was alarmed so one of the doors
was left unlocked it was an emergency
door
and that's how the suspect got in and
they had gotten the alarm hit
through the alarm in the house that that
door had
had some had made someone may have made
entry and that's when the homeowner went
down to check
to see if anybody was inside of the
house
yes sir
yeah you know you see the officers we
always teach our officers to pre-plan
when they get there
so they're out there talking about
planning and then all of a sudden the
game changes or the
the game plan changes because they look
in and they see an individual
inside of the residence you know armed
with a hammer holding a homeowner
hostage
so so basically they have to act quickly
luckily one of the homeowners it was the
wife who was able to
oh i'm sorry the yes the the husband
was able to open the door during that
altercation
and confusion as they were banging on
the door and
once the officer saw the suspect
attempting to injure
or seriously injure that homeowner they
had to take action but
usually we try and plan ahead and come
up with a game plan but it changes
instantly when you see something like
that especially if you look at that
residence
very wide open a lot of windows which
help the officer see in and see exactly
what they had
and there's no indication they knew each
other why this house was targeted
he from what we know he he went into the
residence
up he he had gone into a another
residence
uh behind it or inside of a shed in that
residence
and then he was just basically randomly
trying areas
and and he had actually made a threat to
the homeowner
that before he left he wanted to score
according to them that was their own
work that was a homeowner's words that
he had said to them
and in the briefing also that he was
attempting to take
the female homeowner with him in a
vehicle
and and get some money out of an atm and
she refused to go with him yes ma'am
he did have a he he he does have priors
he had
some militia i don't have them in front
of me but he had some malicious
destruction of prior
property priors he did have a burglary
in may of 2020
in which the d.a confirmed that he went
into a business
a commercial business taking some items
and he was according to the d.a he had
he was in jail for a little bit of time
he was given credit for time served and
the judge released him
so he's out for the same sort of crime
which which he's committing still
yes sir
uh not as of yet and going back to your
last question i may not have answered
part of it but
you know look these these guys have to
act immediately
and to do what they did in that short of
an amount of time i mean these guys are
heroes
i mean you know they have to from what
they see and what they have out there
uh seeing a hammer being raised above a
a
person's head and these homeowners one
was 73 years old one was 68 years old
so they're basically being terrorized in
their own homes so these guys had to do
what they had to do
we don't like getting into
officer-involved shootings but you know
that's part of our job
and it's our last resort we take the
sanctity of life seriously but in that
sort of instance
and that close range that was pretty
much one of their only options
okay thank you all for coming